happens is you've got two sides in an
angle and that's all they give you and
the reason it's ambiguous or unclear is
because you know we don't know what this
angle is it's not a rigid situation
meaning that it's possible that we can
maybe rotate this side to see the six
side we could rotate it in such a way
that maybe another triangle could be
formed so they're just giving us the
information but they're not necessarily
telling us how to draw the triangle or
how to construct it so here's what
you're gonna do you're gonna want to
drop an altitude okay like a
perpendicular to the opposite side like
so okay we have to find out what that
height is now the way that you would do
that is you would say just like in right
triangle trigonometry the sohcahtoa you
would say sine of 30 degrees right
equals the opposite side over the
hypotenuse right so H over 10 now if we
cross multiply you can see H times 1 is
H equals 10 times sine of 30 and the
sine of 30 you can go to your calculator
or if you know this is 1/2 10 times 1/2
is 5 ok so that means that this altitude
is 5 so again like I was telling you
before we don't really know what this
angle is here so what you could do is
you could rotate this in such a way and
think of this as a circle okay I'll try
to draw a decent circle here for us ok
something like that right so this is
like the center of the circle and you're
rotating it so really there could be
another triangle that's formed like this
ok so what you want to analyze is you've
got this longer side here okay adjacent
to the acute angle and the side that's
across from that acute angle if this
side is shorter than the altitude like
say for example whose only 4 if you went
to rotate it like this it wouldn't be
able to reach the opposite side so
there'd be no triangle possible if this
side was exactly the same as the
altitude if this was 5 then when you
went to rotate it it would just barely
touch this side right here and there
would just be one triangle or right
triangle if this side here is longer
than the side adjacent to secure tank
like say this was 11 if you tried to
rotate it like this it would extend past
this side right here so you could only
rotate it out to the right like that so
that would just be one triangle possible
and then what we have here is a special
scenario where at this side excuse me
opposite the acute in
is in between c6 is in between the
altitude and the side adjacent in
between five and ten and so you can see
we can construct this triangle it looks
something like this right and then we've
got the original triangle that I drew
which looks something like this and
again it's just because we're rotating
this side like so now if you want to see
you know all the steps for solving these
triangles and how to work through them
I'll have links to the videos that I did
talking about how to actually solve the
two triangles and so forth let's look at
another example we're gonna talk about
the if you have an obtuse triangle where
this angle is greater than 90 degrees in
this case this was an acute angle is
less than 90 but I just wanted to
mention if you're preparing for the AC T
or the SAT you know you're talking about
trigonometry and these types of things
and you're preparing for those tests I
have a video course for both the SAT
Math section and the a CT math section
I'll have links for those check those
courses out if that's something that you
feel that it would be beneficial they're
excellent courses but let's talk about
this triangle so here we've got an
obtuse angle and the thing that you want
to remember when you have an obtuse
triangle is that the side that's across
from the largest angle should be the
longest side because you know an angles
like a hinge so if I open up that hinge
like that this side is going to be the
longest sides can be open very wide
right but you can see in this case
that's not what's happening at all right
basically we're looking at hmm 8 is
shorter than 10 if I was to really draw
this to scale okay it would look
something like that you see there's this
big gap here this is not long enough you
know to reach this other vertex over
here of the triangle so in this case
there's no triangle possible now if I
was to reverse it make this side e in
this side 10 then there would just be
one triangle possible so when it's an
obtuse angle given like this so is
either gonna be one triangle or no
triangles but not two triangles okay one
other thing I was going to mention about
this ambiguous case here is that
sometimes I write it like this okay it's
a little bit more descriptive it's like
side side angle and notice I did a
lowercase a to represent an acute angle
okay which is what we have here less
than 90 and then I have the side that's
adjacent right next to these next to the
angle that is longer that's why I made
it a capital letter
then the side across that's why I made
this a lowercase s okay so when you have
that set up then you know that there's a
potential for two triangles not
guaranteed you have to check it by
dropping that altitude so I hoped you
enjoyed this video subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon